[Music]
seth welcome to how the light gets in
festival it's great to be here it really
is thank you um so consciousness is
obviously a very big topic for you
what first go are you interested in it
i think
everyone's interested in consciousness
right i mean i remember being a kid and
at some point just asking myself these
questions
who am i what happened where was i
before i was born what happens after i
die
rapidly leads to questions about
why am i having experiences maybe this
is a bit further than some people go but
it's a it's a big question then it's the
kind of thing you talk about in pub with
your friends and it's always been a
strong interest to me how do we define
consciousness and when we talk about it
in this context what is consciousness
it's a very it's a very good question
it's actually very hard to come up with
a consensus definition that everybody's
going to agree on
but i don't think that's necessary at
this stage in science definitions often
evolve along with a greater
understanding of a phenomenon so so long
as we define it in a way that roughly we
know what we're talking about that's
fine and i like philosopher thomas
nagle's definition
that for a conscious organism
there is something it is like to be that
organism put it another way
consciousness is any kind of subjective
experience whatsoever it's not the same
thing as intelligence it's not the same
thing as having language it's not the
same thing as behaving in complicated
ways it's the presence of any kind of
experience whatsoever
you say somewhere that people often
confuse consciousness for intelligence
and therefore leading to kind of
misconceptions around whether
ai is conscious or whether it can become
conscious why do you think we confuse
the two is it because just they
correlate very strongly what's the
what's the reason behind it i don't
think so i think the confusion can be
overstated i think most people do
recognize there's there's a difference
we can talk about consciousness in other
animals that we might not ascribe human
level intelligence to and of course we
think babies are babies are actually
very intelligent manipulating people but
but i think we do recognize as a
difference at some level
but at another level
i think we're tempted to
overstate
their dependency so there are some
theories of consciousness that associate
it
with
being able having a brain that can
reflect on its own activity in in
various ways and of course there is this
idea
that as artificial intelligence
continues to accelerate and maybe
crosses some threshold that the lights
come on and awareness happens i don't
think there's a good reason to why that
should be the case but why do people
think that and i think this is this
really traces to
sort of anthropocentrism this like this
this
tendency humans have to put themselves
at the center of everything in the top
of every pyramid we think we're
intelligent and we know we're conscious
so we tend to associate the two together
you mentioned there's something about
you know the plus the way we think about
it like the lights coming in and kind of
such an awareness coming
uh becoming apparent and that sort of
seems to be referencing a kind of
concept of self-consciousness as aware
how do the two concepts
relate consciousness and
self-consciousness do they go together
or are they separate
consciousness and self are
at a very deep level
for me anyway very very intimately
related but at a different level not
related at all and i want to make that
distinction i think it's important
being a self is not one single thing we
have many aspects that that together
constitute our experience of being who
we are there's this very high level
aspect of self that i am a person with a
set of memories
and a personal identity and a name and a
set of social relations
that's a very
species specific
quite high level aspect of selfhood i
don't think that is remotely
co-extensive with consciousness you
don't have to have that kind of
self-consciousness to be conscious but
there are much more basic forms
of self the experience of just being a
body of being alive of emotion and mood
and the argument that i'm making in the
book and that i've been thinking about
for a few years now is that aspect of
salford that might be really fundamental
to all human consciousness
you've written a an article for us at
the ii which is on the self and in which
you argue that
even though we usually think of the self
as this kind of locus of perception the
point through which we perceive the
world
in fact it is
just another kind of perception the self
is a perception
how do we make sense of this
uh
of a perception without a perceiver as
it were it's difficult to to make sense
of it in everyday life so the idea here
is that indeed the self is not the thing
that does the perceiving the self itself
is a bunch of perceptions it's an old
idea it goes back to hume it's very
present in a lot of eastern spiritual
traditions as well
it seems like at least to most of us
most of the time
that the self is this the recipient
of information from the world and it's
the thing doing the perceiving
it's very hard to actually cash that out
in terms of how things work in the brain
it leads you into this infinite regress
you're postulating some inner homunculus
things don't really work that way at all
it's much more i think
useful to think of the self as
just as a perception that's constructed
in a similar way
to
our perceptions of the outside world
part of the experience of self is
emotion and mood and we can think of
those as particular kinds of perceptions
of the body
that are
underpinned by mechanisms that are very
similar to those that underpin our
experience of things
out there in the world
it's a challenge in everyday life to
really take that on board and you know
i'm a very uh
i'm not a very good meditator but i do
meditate and and one of the things that
in meditation
um happens one of the things that can
happen anyway is
this recognition in the unfolding of
experience that if you really look for
the self
there's nothing to be found
so going back to the nagel definition of
consciousness then like what is it
that's there that it is something to be
like that thing that's there right if
the self is just the perception
what is what is the what is the thing
that it
you know what is the underlying thing is
there's no underlying thing is there any
underlying thing well
it depends of course like all these
things that there's always this tendency
we have we
to think of
ourselves there must be some essence of
me or a view that is in some sense
different from the stuff we're made of
that might survive over time unchanged
that might perhaps even survive the
death of the body
i just don't think that's a
useful idea it doesn't undermine the
value of being yourself at all and the
experience of being yourself does
change
over time
feels continuous it's continuous in some
ways but in other ways
what it's like to be me right now is
quite different from what it was like to
be me a few years ago or certainly 30
years ago yet
it's tempting to think there is still a
stable you know there's an essence of me
that's just
continuous cross all that time and maybe
there are a few cells that are still
there or whatever but that's i don't
think that's particularly relevant now i
think there isn't
any essence
of
of me or you there are just perceptions
which unfold over time
so one of your
lines is that consciousness is a kind of
hallucination of the brain
and i was wondering whether you could
tell us a little bit more about what you
mean by that right so
i talk about conscious experience and
especially conscious perception
as a controlled hallucination and
the control is very important here
equally as important as the word
hallucination because it can be often
misunderstood as saying that like
nothing is real everything we experience
is made up that's absolutely not
what the claim is there is an objective
reality at least i think there is you go
ask a physicist
but the way
this reality appears to us
in our experience is always a
construction
it's not that the world pours itself
into our minds to the transparent
windows of our senses
it's always an active construction
and so this is why there's a continuity
between perception as it normally
unfolds and something like hallucination
we understand hallucination to be an
internally generated perception and it
is so is normal perception the
difference is that hallucination as we
typically understand it
is an internally generated perception
that's lost its grip on on the real
world whereas normal perception is an
internally generated construction that
is very very tightly geared to what's
out there in the world but there's a lot
more to say that i mean just to say so
one of the things that we're doing in in
my lab at the moment is there are many
different kinds of hallucinations people
just use the word but like many things
in language
we're glossing over
a richly informative diversity of
different kinds of experience so one of
the things that we're doing
is now trying to build computational
models
of different kinds of hallucinations for
instance psychedelic hallucinations
involve things like ego dissolution this
this back to our discussion about the
self that seems to dissolve a bit but
perception is altered in a way that it
seems to be a manipulation of what's out
there in the world quite often whereas
the sorts of hallucinations that might
arise in parkinson's disease or dementia
have a very different character and if
we can
understand really what's underpinning
these different kinds of actual
hallucination
that sheds light
back on how normal perception is working
in the here and now for all of us
so your your big project is trying to
demystify consciousness explain
consciousness through science for a long
time it's been a topic that
you know belong to philosophers and
philosophers discuss you know the hard
problem of consciousness and the easy
problem of consciousness and you you
talk about how you know there's this
other problem that you know science
needs to figure out you know the real
the real problem as a ware of
consciousness do you think
science will one day totally sort of
explain away all the mysteries around
consciousness or will there always be
this kind of philosophical component to
the phenomenon that you know science
won't be able to account for well
there'll always be a philosophical
component i mean it's it's fundamentally
as
deeply philosophical as it is scientific
for me the question is you know will
science ultimately dissolve the sense of
mystery that surrounds consciousness
will we still will it still seem
to be this beyond the reach and remit of
science this
this situation where we have on the one
hand conscious experiences and on the
other hand
mere mechanism
uh
my that is that
by trying to as i call it the real
problem by trying to identify and
account for
different properties of consciousness in
terms of mechanisms
that sense of mystery will will dissolve
whether it will dissolve entirely i have
to be honest i don't i don't know but
what else can we do i think
science is the best way coupled with
philosophy not independently i really
don't think they should be
put in opposition and they aren't and
one of the joys of
my career so far is this this productive
interaction of scientifically literate
philosophers and philosophically
literate scientists working uh together
let's see maybe the the question will
dissolve entirely just as
the hard problem of life dissolved we no
longer worry about looking for
an ellen vitalis spark of life
but maybe it won't and that's for the
future to say do you think science will
have to
radically change as aware to incorporate
the phenomenon of consciousness fully to
take into account this kind of
perspectival aspect of it or do you
think science can remain
as it is now this kind of third person
objective view on the world
quantitative mathematical not taking
into account sort of subjectivity i'm
yeah this is a very good question it's a
specific challenge for consciousness
that it is different you can't put a
conscious experience on the table and
look at it in the same way that you can
for other things
in science now this has led
some philosophers and some
neuroscientists and scientists to think
that well you know that means that we
can't do a science of consciousness or
that we can't do an exhaustive science
of consciousness
it's true the data
are harder to get
but we can get data and we can get
descriptions
of people's first person experience it's
challenging but we can we can even infer
something about it in non-human animals
and in infants
as well
so i don't think we
need to
massively change the structure and
nature of science it's not even clear to
me
how we would
but i do think there there is a specific
challenge here and this is one of the
reasons why you have to have a bit of
humility about whether there will be
any residual sense of mystery but i
think the larger reason why there might
be
is simply that we ourselves are
conscious we're trying to explain us
and so we tend to apply a slightly
different standard to what we expect
from scientific explanation than we do
for other things that are not us we seem
to want it to make intuitive sense or to
even actually create this consciousness
somehow and that's just not going to
happen that's not what scientific
explanations do
this
mind body problem goes all the way back
to descartes
if you could have a one-to-one with with
him what would you tell him to convince
him that the mind isn't separate from
the body oh i wouldn't want it i want to
hear what he has to say i wouldn't be
telling him anything i mean i think
descartes comes in for a lot of stick
these days you know for separating the
mind in the body of course he wasn't the
first person to do that and more related
to my own
work he also
said that other animals were mere beast
machines that they were flesh and blood
kind of automata that didn't have
the rational conscious minds that that
imbued ethical and moral status but of
course he was working at a really
complicated time where to profess
certain beliefs about self and
consciousness could rapidly lead to bad
things happening
from the church so i just want to know
from descartes what do you really
thought
leo seth thank you very much thank you
it's a pleasure
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
[Music]